my friends
my sweet babies i've had some proud
moments in my career so far even back
when i was screaming at the dashboard in
my car while parked in a walmart parking
lot which is where i did a lot of my
shows back then for some reason but even
then
on occasion there would be a milestone
which to me was significant since then
there have been other personal
achievements which meant a lot to me but
nothing in my career can come close to
this to the knowledge that my
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus traumatized terrified and
triggered their own words amazon's
employees this is the pinnacle the
summit uh um it's all downhill from here
i'm afraid
so yesterday my friend lives with tiktok
released the video from an amazon
internal meeting where
employees discussed complained about and
consoled each other over
my books actually my books plural not
just john the walrus the whole thing is
so perfect so on the nose that you might
suspect i scripted it and staged it all
myself um it begins with one of the
leaders of the meeting
talking about the trauma
that my book about walruses has caused
let's listen
it's been a very traumatic experience
for transgender amazonians and our
transgender customers what i don't want
to come out of this
is
um
slamming the books team uh with a bunch
of tickets they are already aware of
this
there are things in the space that are
happening
i take it back um i could not have
scripted this because if i had i never
would have included the line
transgender amazonians
that would have seemed too absurd too
contrived it's the kind of lunacy that
only an authentic leftist in his natural
environment could come up with
transgender amazonian sounds like some
kind of
mythical character and
well if the shoe fits
also note how he says that the books
team is quote aware and quote there are
things in this space that are happening
in other words they are actively trying
to suppress the book that's what he's
saying unsuccessfully very
unsuccessfully as it turns out uh
because right now the book is is just
surging on the charts it's in the top
five through the top five for for a day
but they're trying and it's the fact
that they they've been so unsuccessful
and that i was able to figure out a way
to navigate the system a system designed
to make sure that people like me fail
that makes them all the more enraged
as we'll see a little bit later on
for now though let's uh keep on
listening to this clip
johnny the walrus is
a bit of a problematic book uh not a bit
it is
it is not a bit of a problem it's one
hell of a problem um and i would preface
this about what the book's about but the
customer we're going to listen to
does a great job
need to keep a running list here of
superlatives to add to the book cover
when we do a second printing or actually
a third printing because uh the first
printing sold out in a day if you hadn't
heard so he's already given me some good
ones problematic traumatic and one hell
of a problem that last one's especially
great i hope that i want that on my
tombstone when i die one hell of a
problem the customer who called in to
complain one of many complaints we're
told so we're told this is kind of like
a a representative sample
but this customer certainly agrees with
all those assessments about me and about
the book and has a whole lot more to say
about it let's listen
i just checked
your website and
the book
is
still up on there i hate to tell you but
it says that the book that it is shipped
and sold from you
it is by
matt walsh
it is
teaching kids to
kill
well to bully
transgenders
yeah to bully them into committing
suicide the lgbtqia
especially transgenders
the story is about a kid
who likes to pretend he's different
things and one day he pretends he's a
walrus
and
the community tells him
he either has to be a human
or he has to be a walrus or they're
going to kill him he can't be both he
can't pretend anymore now the author
matt walsh just tweeted this yesterday
morning at 804 am
i now have the number one
anti-lgbt book in the country
any further criticism of me or my book
is homophobic
checkmate
you are telling a manual
how to teach kids to bully other kids to
commit suicide
you know what honestly i'm i'm really
mad because i have a
i have a sibling that who is member of
the lgbtq so i'm really mad as well
right now
now if i was inclined to call people
karen's um
i'd certainly say that this person fits
the bill i don't call people that
because it's an anti-white racial slur
so instead we'll just stick with calling
her a shrill hectoring wench
maybe the view should give her a call
she'd be perfect i think as a coast you
might actually be someone from the view
she also lies about the content of the
book claiming that i instruct kids to
kill or at least bully transgenders in
this in this rather dark and gritty
reimagining of my original story she
says that um in my book johnny the
walrus you know johnny is told by the
community that they'll kill him if he
doesn't stop pretending to be a walrus
none of that actually happens in the
book i mean i it's been a little while
since i wrote it i i admit
i'll go back and check but i don't think
i don't remember including any lines in
there about killing transgenders or the
community telling johnny that stop
pretending to be a walruse or we'll kill
you
that's not in there
in fact nothing like that happens
and it makes me concerned for the
woman's health you know i know that um
you can actually get uh and this is true
this is a medical fact i think that you
can get um like brain worms from
exposure to too much cat litter and so
i'm concerned that this cat lady may be
suffering from that condition i mean
jokes on the worms though in that case
because they made it up to her head and
looked around and
found out the place was empty
um she then says that that i called my
own book the number one anti-lgbt book
in the country in fact i didn't say that
i called it because it was and will
always be
if in my heart the num the number one
lgbt book in the country not anti-lgbt
book
so she lied about that too or
hallucinated it meanwhile the amazon
employee on the phone listens to all
this and nods along in agreement
you know he's angry too he says
by this book that the lady just made up
and keep in mind that that amazon itself
they are playing this complaint for the
other employees
and endorsing it
i mean they said up front they like
agree with this that this is a good
description of the book while she just
makes up a version of the book that
doesn't exist
but we somehow have yet to make it to
the best parts
things get more emotional in a second
video as the employees continue to
lament the many ways in which i abused
committed violence against
their algorithms listen
it's bad faith it's basically abuse of
amazon systems and
they're
they're they're intentionally like when
i say they i mean like matt walsh
and his publicity publishing company
and other people like him are taking
advantage of amazon and how the amazon
algorithms work
to promote their particular brand of
hate
and harm on the community
i have taken advantage of amazon without
amazon's clear and affirmative consent i
have used and abused and manhandled its
algorithms
this is the worst case of algorithmic
abuse the world has ever seen
and we aren't done i mean if you're if
you're worried that so far they've cried
over one of my trolling schemes but have
neglected to mention my other ones
don't worry because they do get around
to that also
the other part of this that is equally
disturbing is um
he matt walsh is getting ready to
release
um i believe
um a book called what is a woman and
there's also a
documentary
that comes with it
um
i
jamie lee shared some information with
me about the movie
um the documentary that's going along
with it but people are already talking
about it he tricked
it was very much
that style tricking transgender people
into participating not understanding
what they were participating in and it's
called what is a woman
um one man's journey to answer the
question i mean like it doesn't like
let's just back up for a second and say
does a man even belong in this
conversation no
he doesn't but guess what we're not it's
not even on sale yet and it's
number one in women's studies
and and number one in the other
categories
that it's available in as well
so this is chief mansplaining
chief mansplainer another superlative
first of all how do you know
that i'm not a woman
i mean what is a woman in order to make
that kind of criticism against what is a
woman you first need to be able to tell
me what is a woman but you can't
and that's exactly why the film and book
exist
which you can find out more about when
you go to what whatiswoman.com second
this is no way to speak
to a or about a best-selling women's
studies scholar can i just say
finally we get to the grand finale and
we got to play this this is the
emotional crescendo of the story
when ultimately breaking under the
psychological stress
the guy leading the meeting
begins to weep
watch this and don't laugh
okay this is serious stuff so don't
laugh you you heartless bullies watch
exploiting our systems right our systems
aren't
like they're not set up to catch
you know they can you know the
self-publishing authors they can
categorize their books
however they want
um
and so um
yeah i want to i just
i'm sorry
i i want to preface this with i want to
preface this with i also saw someone
mention that this is really tough
content and
if you're transgender if you're gender
non-binary
take you know and this is super
triggering and this is super it like it
would like i would understand if you
needed to leave this is for education
for people who don't get it who don't
understand and i would understand if if
this was a lot but equally
i want folks to know
um
that we that we're doing this because
this really matters
i understand um i also understand you
know i understand if my book
written on cardboard for preschoolers
about a boy who pretends to be a walrus
is too distressing and disturbing for
you
you know i understand
i understand in other words if you're
mentally ill
i understand i sympathize well actually
i don't really sympathize and come to
think of it i don't really understand
either but i acknowledge it anyway and i
hope you get the counseling you need
or i hope you banish yourself to an
island in the pacific somewhere i'll
take either option really though i'd
prefer the latter because your cry bully
narcissism is a scourge a plague
a cancer on this country
now i want to speak now uh finally
directly to uh these employees at amazon
you're obviously paying
close attention to what i say and do so
i know you'll see this and hear it
and i want you to hear me when i when i
say what needs to be said here this
would be perhaps the most important
message that you ever hear in your life
it's something you should have been told
years ago but never were
and i'll tell you now and here it is
it's not my job
to cater to
your feelings
i in fact
do not care
about your feelings
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content